[Music]
everyone grows up I never forget about
new pay everyone ever hated everyone
moves on but some friendships
Christopher Robin won't last a lifetime
are you glad to see me mister everyone
welcome to London
thank you for the ride director of
finding another life
that was a shelf for that explains why
it's no good for climbing these days
Christopher rocks rated PG in theaters
August er what should happen if you
forget about me Smee unfair oh never
forget about you pay a promise Havel and
I'm a hundred we should be working this
weekend Robin but I promised my wife and
daughter I'd take them away this weekend
all hands on deck he won't be coming to
the cottage well it can't be helped your
life is happening now right in front of
you what to do what to do what to do
what to do indeed fool Christopher Robin
hello the tree I remember was in the
countryside not here in London but
they're opening I suppose it's where it
needs to be that's a silly explanation
watch thank you oh why are you here
oh yes I need your help I've lost all of
my friends let's get to the bottom of
this
look up here I come it would appear that
I am stuck have you do stateand honey I
have not just eating dirty I wonder
which way I always get to where I'm
going by walking away from where I have
been
do you that's the way I got
hello eyo Christopher Robin its you
played its gonna see if identified
piglets I've already stayed far too long
hello everyone so nice to see you all
again watch thank you silly old bear I
was wrong about work I was wrong about
everything and I've got to get back to
my family
farewell Christopher Robin I would have
liked it to go on for a while longer
perhaps it's our turn to save
Christopher
[Music]
you must be Madeleine wait you all the
bear of my father's drawings yes do you
know where he is
I did I just saw the host Rick Buster is
impossible
piglet if anyone wants to clap now is
the time to do it I don't remember being
cheery people say nothing is impossible
but I do nothing every day
no kapu that's not
[Music]
you